we have the first taxpayer funded EV
charging station in the country what
does this say about the state of play
with our EV infrastructure in the
country it's way behind schedule
obviously and it's it's actually taken
back many companies that are thinking
about risking capital and building more
EVS I mean that's what's really started
to affect companies like Ford and
General Motors Ford on their lightning
discovered they were losing 23 to
$29,000 per vehicle they can't raise it
that much higher they won't S any and
that's because there's a lot of issues
around the market including charging
Distribution standardizing on Tesla is a
no-brainer everybody's going to have to
do that because they took private
capital and built their own
infrastructure Which is far more
efficient than when the government does
it hi Mr Wonderful here and I am small
business does your company qualify for
the employee retention credit find out
at Wonder trust.com educate yourself
with a live expert at Wonder trust now
because the ERC program is going to end
soon